you know I had my weekly existential
crisis because okay
I uh I I was just lying in bed and uh
you know just next to Sydney it was
first thing in the morning and she's
just like hmm
is that a gray hair I see over there
[Music]
and I'm like Sydney don't say that don't
don't I think you could Rock gray hair
though huh I think you'll look great
with gray I mean I think okay here's
here's the thing right so now I don't I
don't mind having gray hair yeah I know
okay this I know this sounds like
[__] Copiague
you wear turtlenecks gone yeah you are
built I built people with gray hair yeah
yeah you're gonna look great and it'll
complete the full Arc of gigguk's hair
full anime Pro tag to to mellowed out to
Southeast Asian man yeah yeah you're
gonna go from anime enthusiasts to like
[__] Southeast Asian mathematics yeah
so excited I don't mind having like the
odd gray hair if if I am growing oh my
God I can't believe I'm talking about
this on a podcast but whatever but like
it's it just put like a thought in my
head right just to be like life is a few
times
I am getting old because
um whenever this video is coming out so
like my next uh my next video that I've
been working on this week which will
probably be out uh it's kind of like a
[__] it's it's a full-on [__] djen
anime like full-on d gen manga kind of
level okay and I'm just like I remember
like it was that day where City told me
had a gray hair took the shower started
writing my script and I'm just like
how much longer can I get away with
doing this [__] talking about
degenerative yeah yeah because like I
remember when I was younger right my
parents would be like you're gonna grow
out of anime someday you know you'll
you'll you'll you'll grow out of this
phase someday you're gonna grow up and
then I just never did okay and to be
fair I do not think I'm ever going to
grow out of like anime or gaming or all
this [__] that like our parents told us
we grew out of yeah sure when we were
younger but there are certain things
where I'm like
can I get away with this I know you came
to the realization I came to about two
years ago oh yeah yeah yeah well it's
like I I think obviously anime being
well it's not new but in terms of like
having more of a fandom around in the
west it's certainly yeah more on the
newer end yeah compared to something
like let's say Star Wars which has been
around since
you know and you you look at like the
demographic people go to Comic-Con
you're like a lot of you dudes are like
50 D's or late 40s and it's like well
clearly this is not like nowadays we are
past the because obviously the consuming
media and this type of stuff is all kind
of new and like this generation or the
current generation that's alive so it's
like I think I don't think it's like you
grow out of it anymore I think it's you
if you're if you're still understand
when you're 30 yeah you'll still be into
that thing or something adjacent to it
at 50 yeah 60. I think specific maybe
talking about anime titties yeah you
might do that less okay okay
when do you think you're gonna stop
liking anime ludes on Twitter at what
age do you think it will be become yes
the moment you have a kid you cannot
definitely the moment I have a kid for
sure
um I think I think the moment I have a
kid I'm probably just gonna like just
cut back on social media entirely yeah
yeah yeah would you like I think the
right I think yeah which I think is the
way to go but it's like yeah double it
give it to the next person make the kid
the news
so uh you know his taste it's all his
taste now yeah it's got nothing to do
with me yeah because I'm I've had this
thought because I came to the cam same
conclusion where it's just gonna be like
okay when me and Sydney eventually have
kids that's probably going to be a huge
Catalyst to change some of our Behavior
but just because I know that you know
it's gonna become less socially
acceptable to let's say talk about this
in public it's just something in my
brain Gonna Change to be like okay
actually anime titties uh uncool now you
should you should not like this stuff
because I think so yeah you think so is
that I think it's like a gradual change
of like taste like maybe one thing that
was superlude you might not be as
comfortable interacting with that kind
of stuff yeah but you still like loot
stuff but it's like okay you're slowly
maybe going away from that yeah I mean
I mean even just like my taste in like
you know like the more degenerative
shows or whatever like I remember there
were so many shows when I was like 13 to
15 years of age where I'm just like oh
it's lewd Masterpiece this is the this
is the greatest piece
the greatest piece High School of the
Dead oh yeah and now and now you know
and some of them are still great just
because of the other components that
made that show great but you know I
would say a good eighty percent of those
like lewd shows that I used to think
were like great shows I look at it now
and I'm just like yeah and it's not like
and you know maybe it's because I've
just like grown out of that phase or
maybe because you have a girlfriend well
yeah or maybe it's because I touch grass
I don't know
either by the way my tastes have
definitely changed but I don't regret
that because I feel that's just the
natural process for anyone regardless of
whether you [__] do it for a living
or not right it's like yeah obviously
the shows that you know you thought were
[__] amazing back in the day yeah and
you look back at in retrospect you
probably think to yourself it either
didn't age as well or you're just like
it's not really my wheelhouse anymore
yeah yeah I think that's interesting as
well because on the podcast where you
always talk about what we like dislikes
our opinions and stuff because that's
all we ever do yeah and I've noticed
that it started happening more and more
which people be like oh he is one of us
says something that contrary to someone
we said three years ago yeah and it's
like okay trash is gonna get that point
where as we're growing older and we're
changing our opinions and our views on
things yeah yeah we're obviously going
to contradict what we said three years
ago yeah because we're going to change
our mind on this isn't it it's so weird
having to do that isn't it insane to
think that opinions change well it's not
crazy isn't it insane to think that we
just say dumb [__] so yeah sometimes we
don't speak but I can understand why a
viewer can get that because it's like
you have this kind of
want it's like a a cat like a a complete
video that is a complete Recreation of
you three years ago it's completely
there and you saying that thing and it's
still you today who is that person in
the video so it's very easy I think for
a person to think that why would their
opinion change because I It Feels So
recent and so accessible this opinion
yeah when obviously you said it three
years ago yeah and they don't see the
entire Journey or follow that entire
journey of how you changed your mind
yeah on things yeah sometimes it doesn't
even it's not even like a matter of like
time you know it could just be something
like you thought about this one thing
maybe because you were you know
uneducated in it or you didn't have
enough information you didn't have
enough of like a scope on it and then
once you got the more full picture and
you really thought it through then
you're like oh you know what maybe my
prior opinion on that was just wrong or
you know isn't wasn't reflective of what
I think now in my current headspace and
you know that could happen as early as
like [__] within the year with some
people you know it's like sometimes one
yes yeah some one person could say one
thing that just completely shifts your
mind on it and yeah your your opinions
change on that forever but on the world
of the internet where any video of any
timeline is accessible at any time
someone will look at and be like oh look
see he's contradictioning himself I'm
like who doesn't ever everyone
contradicts themselves that's what an
opinion is opinions are supposed to
change yeah did you did you guys okay
like going back to what it means like
grow up and like change your opinion
like be an adult did you guys have this
like image of let's say you're like you
know in your late teens going into like
you know 17 18 year olds going to
University or whatever and you had like
this image about how adults are like
supposed to act like oh once you finish
High School adults are meant to act this
way or once I finish University go into
the Working World adults are meant to
act that way and then you you actually
do grow up uh and you go into the
Working World you go into University and
you just have this like image in your
mind about how people your age are
supposed to act and then you've realized
holy [__] people do not act the way that
I thought they would at all there's that
but there's also the opposite where it's
like you you look at an adult say like
your parents right or your dad or
whatever and you think like
not every dad likes this kind of [__]
like I'm not gonna be like that when I
get older and then you know and then you
grow up and you're like holy [__] I used
to think trips to Ikea were boring as
[__] and now I'm super excited to see
this new couch like and it's not even
like a matter of like you know you
growing up it's just like oh this is
just like a natural progression that
every adult goes through whether you
like it or not and it's like and it's
not and you get old enough to the point
where you realize oh it's not even cool
trying to go against that grain because
now everyone's doing it yeah you know
it's like there isn't a single adult out
there who's like you like Furniture
[__] Normie like no one's like that
it's like it's just a natural thing that
like
as an adult there's nothing wrong with
and it's completely a natural
progression to just adopt those like
interests and styles regardless of how
you label how you grow up